joining us right now in the Direct TV 4k
NBA report is a man who has been
covering the association for over two
decades the senior NBA reporter for
bleacher report Howard PAC how you been
Howard how are you I'm doing great
thanks I'm doing great what would you
say is the top story out of the first
action Jam action-packed 5 days of the
Association season Howard oh man I don't
know there's one overarching story other
than you know holy crap it really blows
watching a couple of players go down
with season-ending injuries right off
the top and several others hobbling off
with you know injuries that we don't
know the extent of yet you know Gordon
hey what an opening night that was just
that was devastating to see and it
certainly changes things competitively I
think atop the East Jeremy Lin you know
obviously the nets are not a contender
but very important to that team and a
team that's trying to dig its way out of
a major hole over the last couple of
years so and you just hate seeing guys
going down period and then you know me
elicits a low dose [ __ ] hobbling off
with the Clippers a couple days ago so
in a strange first few days yeah and
then the fight with the Bulls right I
mean how does that how does that sort
itself out I know you know we heard from
Portis this past week saying that you
know his text and his clothes have yet
to be returned but how does that get
ironed out Howard you know I've seen
plenty of situations where teammates
that didn't particularly like each other
or have had issues with each other still
managed to you know play productively
and stick it out and it's fine some
situations not I don't know enough about
those two or the bowl situation to know
how that one resolves but I got to
believe that when all is said and done
when you know when meera touches back
from the broken face and when Portas
suspension is over it's been probably
not
after that time probably right now the
so the Bulls are having to figure out
how to sort this out that at some point
I think you're moving off of one or both
of these guys I can't imagine after
something that serious that you're going
to keep them in the same locker room
that just doesn't seem wise this is not
a bygones be bygones situation
in my eyes that's it's a little too too
violence to just say hey let's say cans
and we're all good let's uh and then
there's the firing of Earl Watson I mean
the sons became just the third team in
NBA history replaced their coach within
the fourth game four first four games of
a season it that sounds like a hockey
move basically Howard were you surprised
by that no because even though it seems
really early to be firing a coach and
yet technically so you could also say
that it was overdue based on performance
over the last year or so and whether or
not they should have ever made him coach
in the first place Mineral Watson didn't
have a ton of bench experience when they
made him in a room and then and then the
full time head coach it was a strange
move Robert Sauber though is one of the
cheaper owners in the NBA and has not
been one of the more adept owners in the
NBA to boot and so you know promoting a
guy with very scant experience that most
people didn't think was ready to be a
head coach you know that's the owners
mistake you know the Earl Watson paid
the price for Roberts server and that's
that organization overreaching and
they're also underachieving they're
underachieving because of a roster that
really isn't ready to compete either and
again that's on the organization which
is not to excuse
Watson's coaching it's just to say that
there's a lot going on in Phoenix that
goes way beyond whether or not or Watson
with the right guy for the job
Howard back from Bleacher Report joining
me here in the Direct TV 4k NBA report
on the Rich Eisen show is there any
there there between what we're reading
or hearing about the Dwyane Wade and his
presence there in Cleveland isn't truly
welcomed by a lot of the players in
Cleveland other than LeBron Howard you
know I think the real issue there is
just that you know you come in and you
know very latent in the in the going
there you've got a pretty tight group
that's formed around LeBron that's his
new championship group as opposed to his
old one and Dwayne and LeBron are really
close friends obviously so he comes in
and has immediately made a starter at JR
Smith expense you're going to be a
little protective of your own if you're
a teammate certainly grr Smith is
justified in feeling a little bit of
shape well that said the news today out
of Cleveland practice was that Dwyane
Wade and Terron Liu had a discussion in
which Wade suggested maybe he should go
to the bench and that's what there
going to do so Wayde will go to the
bench junior Smith is back in the
starting lineup and any strain on you
know chemistry and and there you know
internal relations there I think will
probably be fine you know going forward
and Wade is a great guy to be leading
that second unit and so you know
obviously with the injury of Gordon
Hayward and then the intrigue as always
with Cleveland does this open the door
for Milwaukee based on what we have seen
over the first three games from the
Greek freak Jonas
identical Bowl did I say that name right
by the way Howard
Yanis okay why okay and out of the
crumpled it's a lot to spit out under
the cumin taken okay it's taken years of
practice for me I love it um I I think
it's interesting rich in a normal season
we would be seeing something like oh you
know the Cavs are vulnerable because
they had to trade their second best
player in Kyrie Irving they've got you
know Isaiah Thomas is not back till
January at least maybe won't come back
we don't even know for sure we don't
know what he'll look like when he comes
back they have all these new players
they're trying a new lineup with Kevin
Love at center we in a normal situation
we'd be talking about them being
vulnerable but Boston was a complete
overhaul and now they've lost Gordon
Hayward so now they don't seem much like
a threat I don't know
who would be the threat maybe Milwaukee
you know Yanis is certainly taking
literally and figuratively massive leaps
on a you know year-to-year basis here
and you've got you know a lot some good
young players around him but I don't
know if they're ready to make that kind
of leap yet and then Toronto and
Washington our two teams that have been
hovering him near the top of the East
for the last couple of years but just
have not been able to make that quantum
leap to Cleveland's level and I'm not
sure that either of them did you know
now neither of them did really anything
in the offseason to close that gap so
it's more about Cleveland if Cleveland
malfunctions on its own then it opens
the door but if Cleveland you know and
look they've got LeBron he's the
ultimate equalizer all they have to do
is just be competent and they'll
probably hold everybody off and then in
terms of the Warriors are you surprised
with their won and to start and Steph
Curry throwing his mouth
guard getting ejected and and the way
that they started this season Howard I'm
more I'm more surprised with Steph and
Kevin Durant losing their cool in Game
three of the season and getting ejected
in tandem than I am with a one and two
stars it happens you know I mean we all
have high expectations for them they
have high expectations their talent is
is still you know by far ahead of
everybody else in the league and we all
expect them to win the championship in
June but you know teams have some early
stumbles sometimes David they did go to
China and back didn't have a full
training camp this was a year with
shorter training camps anyway so maybe
guys just aren't quite in sync yet we'll
see but I don't I don't read too much
into that and then the two things I
guess we learned about Lonzo balls first
week is one his dad's gonna fire back
when somebody fires in his direction
like Patrick Beverley did and then to
that even if he does have off nights
shooting he is going to contribute in
other ways he's damn near gotten to
triple doubles in his first three games
how do you read it Howard yeah those are
the two things I think we knew going in
we knew that Lavar ball was going to say
a lot of crazy things loudly and you
know emphatically whenever he you know
whenever the mood struck which is
probably often and we knew that Lonzo
was going to be a guy who while not a
great score or shooter at least was
going to have a huge impact on the game
in so many other ways especially with
his playmaking and we've seen it I mean
I think he has been look he's gonna have
his ups and downs and everybody was
ready to bury him after opening night
when Pat Beverley locked him up and
everybody is ready to jump back on the
bandwagon when he gets in your
triple-double in his second game there's
gonna be ups and downs like any with any
other rookie with any other
nineteen-year-old who's got you know
very little experience and by the way a
really young cast around him too so the
Lakers are gonna you know have a lot of
consistency issues their defense is not
good they're not going to be spending
for a playoff berth but Lanza is going
to be a reason to wash it they're going
to be more entertaining more competitive
just by his presence Howard always
appreciate the time good chat with you
again we're off and running on another
season we'll chat with you again real
soon
look forward to it rich thanks for
having me always at Howard
on Twitter check out the full 48 podcast
by bleacher report with Howard and then
of course at Howard Beck as I mentioned
on Twitter for more Rich Eisen show
tuned - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app